>> Okay.
Arthur: This time last year Zimbabweans were
going into an election and those election
were inconclusive.
As a result Zimbabweans came together to discuss
the way forward.
As I speak this in [inaudible] Zimbabwe which
was rectified by our colleagues yesterday.
In hands we know have a conclusive and legitimate
government in Zimbabwe.
What we are calling upon the international
community to do is to respect this agreement.
To assist Zimbabweans as they try to cast
a way forward.
The inclusive governments that we are setting
up in Zimbabwe next week is the only way forward.
It is a short term measure to extricate our
country from its worst situation.
The agenda of this government has four elements.
The first one is resolving the humanity crisis
in our country, food and cholera.
The second area is national healing.
Our people were traumatized and brutalized
in June last year.
We need to heal our people in Zimbabwe.
Number three, we need to recover and stabilize
our economy.
And the last agenda of this government is
building and developing a new people democratic
constitution.
Going through referendum, there after, we
can have a free and fair election in Zimbabwe,
where there will be one winner who can then
form a proper government.
This is what we intend to do.
We need the international community, we need
regional leaders, we need the African union
to support this arrangement where Zimbabweans
have agreed to work amongst themselves to
salvage their country.
This is not about partisan interests this
is not about personal interests, it is about
the national interest in Zimbabwe.
It is about the people of Zimbabwe who are
dying.
We have come together in Zimbabwe because
we realize we need to be flexible, pragmatic
and reflective of the interests of the people
of Zimbabwe.
So yes we've had our reservations about that,
but that stops right here.
We must serve our people and absolve this
current [inaudible] if we don't do the right
thing and serve our country.